now though we've already been talking
about the rise in kovac 19 infections
levels and the measures that's been
taken to try and tackle that
so let's stick with what that theme and
we can talk now to the health secretary
matt hancock thank you very much for
being on the programme
now i know you don't want to have
another national lockdown like the one
that we saw
from march but should we be preparing
for
more national restrictions
well the nation faces a tipping point
and we have a choice and the choice is
either that
everybody follows the rules the rule of
six
and the need to self-isolate if you have
a positive test or if you're contacted
by
nhs test and trace or
we will have to take more measures
and i don't want to see
more measures more restrictive measures
but unfortunately
if people don't follow the rules
that's how the virus spreads and we know
so much more about
the virus and how it spreads now than we
did last time
and we can see what people need to do
and that's why we have these super
simple rules the
rule of six and then if you've got a
positive test
or if you've been a contact of somebody
who's a positive test
you must self-isolate and we're bringing
in this stronger
this stronger rules around that
self-isolation
with the support for people who need to
self-isolate
so that everybody must do it
um it's some pretty tough rules you're
bringing in as you say
fines if you fail to self-isolate up to
ten thousand pounds it's a legal duty
and you're talking about how important
it is if you knew of somebody who was
breaking that
who should be self-isolating and they
weren't would you report on them
yes and everybody should and the reason
for that
is that the way that we control this
virus is by breaking
the chains of transmission and the
number one
thing that everybody can do is the
basics
hands face and space they save lives
and making sure that if you
that you follow the rule of six and the
social distancing
everybody has got a part to play in this
it's so important
and then if you test positive
and or if you've been a contact and
had nhs test and trace phone you up and
say that you must self-isolate
then it is absolutely critical that you
do
to break that chain of transmission and
to
stop the growth of this virus and it's
because it's so important
that we've brought in this this
mandation with the
fines of up to ten thousand pounds if
you don't do it but at the same time
we've brought in support financial
support
for anybody on on low incomes five
hundred pound payment
to make sure that everybody can do it
and also that everybody must do the
self-isolation and it's the combination
of these two the support
but also the requirement to stick by the
rules
that is going to help to break these
chains of transmission and to keep the
virus under control and as i say
this is a really difficult moment you're
talking about how
important it is that people follow the
rules um
my question to you is what does your
data show are people following the rule
of six
are people getting a bit lacks and if
they are getting lacks
does that mean that national
restrictions could be around the corner
well people have got more relaxed over
the summer
and of course i understand that and you
know we're all human
but now is the moment when everybody
needs
to get back to the the rule of six
the uh the the hands face space
so are you worried about people breaking
the rules then
are you worried about the data yes of
course and if
i wasn't worried about people breaking
the self-isolation rules we wouldn't be
bringing in 10 000 pound fines
to make sure that everybody who needs to
self-isolate
does self-isolate but as i say every we
also bring in the support alongside that
so that people have that financial
support and we've seen you asked about
the data
we have seen in the data the that some
people
who need to self-isolate not doing so
and of course if you've been asked to
self-isolate then you are
highly you either definitely have
coronavirus or you are highly likely to
have coronavirus
and so it is mission critical that you
isolate
and this self-isolation isn't like you
know in lockdown
what it was for everybody it means you
do not leave your home
you're talking about the need for
everyone to follow the rules and i can't
help but think but
to get people to follow the rules you
have to get people to believe in them to
think that they're
fair to see why they're being imposed
you know just to take one example grouse
shooting exempt from the rule of six
why is it okay for 30 men to kill grouse
but it's not okay
for seven children to feed ducks
no um the there are a number of sports
that fit within the rule of six because
of the distance
you know because you're you're further
apart and so
absolutely we allow for
an organized football organized well
organized cricket until the weather
turns
organized sports and the
rule of six is there for a reason and
everybody
everybody understands one of the reasons
uh no because i think sports are a
really important uh priority where
they're organized
well it's just within a sports category
of sports
and the and sports broadly are important
and best done in a covered secure way
so if you think you know let's step back
what is the overall strategy
the overall strategy is to suppress the
virus as much as possible
protecting education and employment and
we also protect
organized sports where it's organized so
there are covered secure rules
because it's so good for people's for
people's health
and in this second wave i want people i
want to be able to
you know keep as much of the nhs going
as possible i want to
learn from what we've learned from last
time we've put in
we've got a plan and stronger rules
around social care along with
over half a billion pounds of support
we've got a plan
to keep the nhs going as much as is
possible
and almost three billion pounds of extra
support
and and for instance the bigger
accidents and emergencies that we
announced last week we've got a plan to
get through this as best we can
but it is critical that every single
person plays their part
everyone faces a choice and it comes
down to the individual moments you know
okay
should i go to that party where i think
there might not be social distancing the
answer is
no you should not and we're going to put
in both the support
but also the the clarity around those
rules so that everybody knows what they
need to do
if that doesn't happen uh people of
course will be thinking about what
restrictions what measures could be
imposed there's just two things i want
to ask you about quickly
lots of talk about a two-week circuit
break is that under consideration
and also the london mayor sadiq khan has
been saying that further restrictions
are increasingly likely in london
is he right well as you know
the um the local approach to taking
action is something that we've
increasingly relied upon the first line
of defenses
is what in everybody does is individual
behavior and social differencing
and we're strengthening that two-week
circuit break and restrictions in london
what's the answer to that well that was
the answer i was giving so the first
line of defense
is people's behavior the then after that
local lockdowns are necessary and i've
brought
in a local action right across different
parts of the country
where cases are rising and you'll have
seen last week that i did that in the
northeast
and in lancashire and other parts of the
country
and i mean i've had discussions this
week with the mayor of london
and the teams are meeting today to
discuss further
what might be needed but in terms of a
national action of course we don't rule
that out
but everybody wants to avoid it i want
to avoid it i see the economic impact of
it and i want to avoid it
and in a way i'm requesting
the help of the british people because
we truly
have got to do this together i agree
with what kierstama said toward the end
of that interview
when he said we all need to come
together once again
to fight this virus every single person
watching this program
has a part to play we will support
people to do the right thing
and we will come down hard on people who
do the wrong thing
but you have a choice every viewer has a
choice
about whether we end up with this virus
going out of control
and it is it comes down to the
individual choices
of the 60 million people who live in
this country as to
as to whether we can keep it there with
the local
uh lockdown approach or whether we have
to take further national action
um part of the equation as well is
testing and the test and trace system
which does appear to be under some
pretty severe strain right now demand
three or four times greater than supply
i'm honestly a bit confused about what
has happened so i was wondering
whether you can explain it to me because
i should keep reminding us we're doing a
lot of testing we're testing more than
france germany
south korea but the system is still
overwhelmed
why is that is there a problem with
processing at the labs
is there a problem that we're not we've
just
underestimated the number of people who
need tests what's gone wrong
so it's very it's very in a way it's
very simple what happened
and what the challenge has been over the
last week
and um and everybody again can play
their part in helping to fix it
so capacity is at record levels it's now
at over
a quarter of a million capacity per day
and as you say that's bigger than
almost any other country around the
world
the um the problem is that we suddenly
got a spike in people who
don't have symptoms coming forward for a
test
uh and that meant that the demand went
from below
the capacity we've got to above it and
and that led to enormous frustration
amongst people who who did have symptoms
and wanted a test i totally get that and
understand that
um and we have thankfully over the last
couple of days
since this has been widely discussed and
i've been out and about and you know
we've had people out about saying
only come forward if you have uh the
symptoms and don't come forward if you
haven't we have seen thankfully
the demand starting to come down again
to more manageable levels i don't
understand
but we've got to keep to understand as
well is why
this surge in demand wasn't seen so
baroness harding the head of test and
trace said this week
that nobody was expecting to see the
really sizable increase in demand i mean
honestly i find that quite astonishing
you know children get temperatures colds
coughs all the time and
you're a parent the prime minister's a
parent why did no one think that oh yeah
when nurseries and schools go back
there's going to be a huge demand
for testing yeah so
the of course there's an uh we expected
an increase in demand due to people with
symptoms
but what what nobody could have
predicted was that a whole load of
people who don't have symptoms you
encourage people to come forward for
testing as well you encourage people to
come forward to testing too on the 21st
of july you said
if you have symptoms or if you have any
doubt if you have
to get attacked
if you have symptoms exactly right or if
you have any doubt
of course about whether about the
symptoms but not if you don't have
symptoms
and of course in the summer capacity was
well above demand
and so we did give anybody who came
forward a test
and you know i wanted to do that because
because we had that capacity available
now that demand is above capacity
it's very important that we prioritize
people with symptoms and again
every single person has a role to play
in this very quickly
zacchaeus dahmer said that the prime
minister should apologize for what's
happened with testing will you apologize
no because i strongly and emphatically
support my
team who have done an amazing job at
building capacity to over a quarter of a
million tests a day
from almost nothing and they've done i i
will just yeah i will endlessly defend
my team they've just put
doing the most amazing work day in day
out seven days a week
absolutely brilliant brilliant people
sorry to move on and it's just that i do
really want to get in question about
care homes which i know is
such an important issue something that
many people will be very worried about
you know 20 000 people in care homes
died with covid 19. and many people
think that one of the big mistakes this
government made was discharging people
from hospital with covert
back into care homes potentially seeding
new infections there
now i just want to read you the guidance
for care homes on the government website
that was updated earlier this month it
says
a small number of people may be
discharged from hospital within the 14
day period
from the onset of covert 19 symptoms
there will have been covid19 tested
and have confirmed covert positive
status
what is going on are we about to make
the same mistake again
no we we we must look after people who
have
a positive test for covert of course we
must
and they have to go if they are
if they need to leave hospital and of
course hospital is also
a a a challenging environment
then they must go into isolation and the
cqc's role
is to ensure that that isolation is
uh is done effectively um so we
absolutely will protect
care homes from people both you know
whether it's
staff moving between care homes and that
has we've got to see an end
of that the regular testing in care
homes one of the
one of the challenges one of the reasons
that we have a very public challenge in
the testing system
is because of the quarter of a million
capacity i send
over a hundred thousand tests a day to
social care
so that they get weekly testing of staff
and monthly testing of residents to keep
people safe
and i will keep doing that no matter
what the public pressure
and then the rules around discharge are
all about if somebody has
a positive test and everybody gets
tested
on the way into a care home if somebody
has a positive test they must be
isolated
and uh and made sure that they therefore
uh protect from the spread
understand uh the precautions you put in
place but do you think some people are
still concerned
about the idea that people could be
moved to care homes just finally
the last six months has been the kind of
six months no you can't
help i'm sorry i'm sorry i just want to
you can't you can't just throw out a
comment like that um
these rules are incredibly stringent
about the need for isolation
if people how easy is it for ketones to
isolate compared to hospital settings
are you talking about tests well we know
that the number of satellite tests
are now being turned around in on
average in
much less than the 24-hour period and we
know of course
that the the when you discharge people
with covered 19 before to care homes
there are concerns that seeded
infections some people will be very
worried that this is about to happen
again
yeah i understand the concerns and
that's why we've been working so hard on
it
if if a care home doesn't have isolation
facilities or we don't think they're
good enough
nobody will go to that care home who
test positive
and we have isolation facilities outside
of care homes precisely for this
reason i the reason i wanted to come
back to this point is because
it's so important to uh to ex to explain
what we're doing to isolate people so
that there will not be
positive people with coronavirus going
into the
general care of care homes it's just
incredibly important
and it's incredibly important of course
that that happens for the reasons that
we all understand
um finally the last six months the kind
of six months that
no health secretary would hope that they
would ever have to face
um tens of thousands of people died the
prime minister saying that we're now
in the second wave how
worried are you about the virus and have
you got the stamina for
the fight ahead
well um on the last point yes
personally i feel incredibly
motivated to do the right thing um and
um and we've built a very very strong
team uh who are putting that in place
and you know this care home uh example
is a is a good one
you know i could get less flack from the
papers by putting
more uh tests into the drive-through
centers
but but i'd have to take them away from
people who who
are the most vulnerable to to dying in
care homes
so i'm gonna do the right thing there
not the easy or
uh or or popular thing um the
um and you know it's that that is what
motivates me so
you know i just get up every morning and
do the best i possibly can
for the nation and then i go to bed at
night and when i wake up the next day
i do the same and that's how i can sleep
easy at night
and but of course i'm very worried and
i'm very worried about this
second wave and we've seen in other
countries around europe how it can
absolutely shoot through the roof
we've actually though seen how you can
tackle it and
you know come with me to belgium where
they saw a second wave very similar in
shape to what we're seeing here
and then they brought in extra measures
and crucially everybody
did their bit and followed them and then
they brought that second wave back under
control without a full-blown national
lockdown
but just with more restrictions on
essentially on socializing
so we can get through this together but
i can't under
on i can't under emphasize the
importance of the message
today right now which is you must follow
the rules
you must follow all of the social
distancing rules
on all occasions and that way we can
avoid
a an incredibly difficult
lockdown again and instead we can get
through this
until the until the cavalry come of the
uh
of the of the vaccine and the mass
testing and the treatments that are on
the horizon
okay matt hancock health secretary thank
you very much for being on the show
today thank you